les japonais sont ainsi qu'auteur oui il
faut notre top 2 ça va faire plaisir à
jean michel c'est un jeu sexy comme il
en existe beaucoup au japon on va en
voir d'autres après la cjue richard non
pas du tout là vous allez voir c'est des
mecs en slip qui doivent pousser une
roue en évitant des obstacles pour
détricoter le plus d'une jeune fille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a dédié sa gueule voilà c'est ça date
de quand ses avants mitu après me to
pass est né à se demander si on
s'immisce france les miss france peuvent
défiler en maillot de bain deux salles
deux ambiances quoi exactement
un peu unique difficile à faire avec
isabelle et pourquoi donc ça c'est tout
ce que vous avez retenu de lyon va
passer sur un moment un peu coquin je
préfère prévenir je pense que jean
michel le corre et plein de jeux coquins
japon qui sont ces accrocs avec ça
existe
si vous avez des exemples pour nous bah
oui mais je sais pas si je peux
tellement dire vous le soyez correct il
ya notamment un jeu où on d il ya des
gens qui marche à quatre pattes comme ça
des hommes marchent quelques pâtes avec
un slip kiabi b2 d'une hormone qui
attire les les chiens les chiens voilà
et du coup les doivent se sauver les
chats essaie de les attraper et donc ils
sont en train de monter dessus et ça va
faire le plus de mettre juste pourquoi
vous raconter bien pourquoi faire le
geste des trous comme ça où les femmes
mettent leur sapin ou leur sexe et
l'homme on voit pas le visage est
l'homme qui jeune maé doit retrouver à
qui appartient la baisse avait été de 3
sur tf1 et quelques années avec fabrice
sur les poitrines sur les poitrines y
avait un jeu où il devait retrouver la
routine de sa compagnie a marre de
culture quand même il faut pas ça dans
les amours c'est à dire que c'était
parce que comme vous dites que ça a
l'impression la fille au bout du café
[Rires]
que dire enfin pas ici parce que c'est
compliqué csa et tout mais je mets au
défi isabelle tu mets 50 sexe masculin
comme sage dans un trou de retrouver
celui de son mari
alors là sur 50 celui d'alain sombret
sud alain alors une friperie
elle en a franchement pas en vue le cas
est le sien pardonne moi donc aller les
enfants pendant deux secondes vous
pouvez vous présenter devant la télé ça
sèmerait une compilation des des jeux
coquins enfin le prix au japon sur les
grandes chaînes nationales en deuxième
partie de soirée on retrouve des
émissions très très coquine voire
carrément sexiste des programmes sans
aucun filtre comme ce concours où deux
candidats doivent faire un maximum de
suçons sur des fessiers anonyme
et attention énorme twist à la fin les
candidats découvrent s'ils ont embrassé
les fesses d'un homme ou d'une femme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'on a le passionne a priori au japon
on adore le curling ce sport où il faut
faire avancer une pierre à l'aide de
balai pour atteindre la cible dans la
version coquine japonaise les pierres
sont remplacés par des femmes les cibles
par des sextoys en revanche on garde
quand même les malaises on reste dans
l'univers de la glisse avec cette
émission qui met au défi les
participants de s'approcher au plus près
de la poitrine d'une jeune femme sans la
toucher sous peine de se faire
électrocuter dans la croix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on enchaîne avec une nouvelle épreuve
sur réaliste devant des faux chirurgien
plastique des candidats doivent pas le
pdi paire de seins en devinant lesquels
sont fausses et lesquelles sont naturels
et pour finir voici une émission qui
mixe habilement supplice corporelle et
érotisme des hommes doivent dégrafer des
soutiens gorge à l'aide de fil relié à
leur corps par des pinces à linge
[Applaudissements]
les charges de sang qui se dit je n'ai
pas fait ma carrière je vais faire
carrière au japon
mais oui elle est d'origine il faut
quand même dire que réjouissons nous que
ça vienne pas en france beaucoup de ces
jeux sont extrêmement dégradant pour
l'image de la femme c'est pas pareil
jean michel six je suis d'accord avec
michel c'est dégradant pour les deux
princesses que notamment même le fils
quant aux hoquets la vie et se fait dès
fricoter son pull mais les mecs en
couches culottes des des coûts dans la
tronche
et là avec l'ess que c'est vraiment très
valorisant pour les musts de l'eau lancé
sûre pour le pilotage de sa part dont
elles peuvent fausser un vrai symbole
est pas bien doré vient succéder granit
et dégradants ça c'est beau perdant mais
surtout c'est pas un viol que dégradant
des jeux
qu'est-ce que tu risques il avait dit
j'ai pas entendu moi non plus je te sais
monsieur 4 vous avez des états qui
parlent à sa place
non mais je crois que c'est pas le but
le but mais aussi s'amuser avec sa vie
parce que je pense que celui qui allait
par sa linge pour retirer le soutien
gorge c'est pas spécial s'il est saisi
pour justement au fait un peu
d'excitation
là c'est dégradant grotesque sûrement
pas excitant il ya une blague a passé un
peu inaperçu boitel
c'est pas les ponts signe son voile a
donné là j'étais bien mais jamais tout à
fait ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]